BUT, FIRST, TODAY PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AND CALLING FOR
FUNDING OF THE BORDER WALL
TWEETING, QUOTE:
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
MUST COME TOGETHER FINALLY
WITH A MAJOR BORDER SECURITY
PACKAGE WHICH WILL INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THE WALL AFTER
40 YEARS OF TALK, IT'S
FINALLY TIME FOR ACTION.
FIX THE BORDER FOR ONCE AND
FOR ALL NOW.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT'S CALL
FOR ACTION COMES AS OVER
6,000 MEMBERS OF THE MIGRANT
CARAVAN HAVE REACHED THE
MEXICAN BORDER TOWN OF
TIJUANA AND AT ONE POINT AS
A SMALLER GROUP OF
PROTESTERS BROKE AWAY FROM
THE CARAVAN AND GOT WITHIN
500 FEET OF THE U.S. BORDER.
AND IN AN INTERVIEW RELEASED
YESTERDAY, GET THIS, HILLARY
CLINTON TOLD THE GUARDIAN
THAT EUROPE NEEDS TO GET A
HANDLE ON IMMIGRATION TO
STOP THE GROWTH OF RIGHT
WING POPULIST.
HILLARY SAYS, QUOTE:  I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
EUROPE HAS DONE ITS PART AND
MUST SEND A VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE REFUGE AND SUPPORT
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T DEAL
WITH THE MIGRATION ISSUE IT
WILL CONTINUE TO ROIL THE
BODY POLITIC.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
IS AMERICA FIRST ACTION
SENIOR ADVISOR AND FORMER
TRUMP PRESS SECRETARY SEAN
SPICER.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR DEROY
MURDOCK AND NATIONAL BORDER
PATROL COUNCIL VICE
PRESIDENT ARE A TELL GET
TOE.
GOOD
GEOD
GETD
QUTD
QUET
QUEO I
HAVE TO START WITH HILLARY
BECAUSE I ALWAYS LIKE TO
START WITH HILLARY.
THIS WOMAN, DID SHE HAVE A
LOBOTOMY?
WHY IS SHE SAYING WE HAVE TO
TELL EUROPE TO STOP THE
MIGRATION IT'S A ROIL TO THE
BODY POLITIC.
SEAN SPICER, HIT IT.
>> I'M NOT SURE IF ANYONE IS
LISTENING TO HER.
THAT'S THE BIGGER ISSUE.
IT'S FUNNY, FIRST SHE STANDS
IN THE WAY OF IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
SHE DOES EVERYTHING SHE CAN
TO STOP IT -- STOP DEALING
WITH IT IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND, YET, SHE WANTS TO
PREACH TO EUROPE WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE DOING.
COMES UP TO THIS KOOKY
RESPONSE HAD INTO THEIR
BORDERS AND OPEN BORDER
POLICIES GIVEN RISE TO THE
POPULIST MOVEMENT THAT
CREATED BREXIT AND TRUMP.
I DON'T REALLY EVEN FULLY
APPRECIATE WHAT SHE IS
TRYING TO GET THROUGH.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A BUNCH OF
GOBBLABLY GOOK TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
>> YOU KNOW, DEROY I
PERSONALLY WAS SHOCKED
MOMENTARILY.
I THOUGHT IT THROUGH.
I SAID TO MYSELF THE TRUTH
IS THAT SHE WILL CHANGE HER
OPINION, SHE AND BILL ARE
NOTORIOUS FOR THIS BASED ON
THE WAY THE WIND BLOWS.
IT TELLS ME ONE OF TWO
THINGS THAT SHE IS A
CHAMELEON, ABSOLUTELY.
>> YES, SHE IS.
>> Judge Jeanine: SECONDLY
SHE IS WILLING TO THROW THE
REFUGEES TO THE WOLVES
BECAUSE SHE THINK IT'S
HELPING THE POLITICS OF HER
OPPONENT.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU
ABOUT HER?
>> WELL, I MEAN VERY SIMPLE,
TAKE WHATEVER ARGUMENT
MAKING ABOUT EUROPE AND
APPLY IT HERE.
IF WE HAVE THIS SITUATION OF
CHAOS OF PEOPLE BREAKING IN
FROM THE GUATEMALA MALL
ALAN, MEXICAN BORDER AND
BREAKING INTO OUR BORDER AS
WELL FUEL PEOPLE WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS WE HAVE
TO HAVE BORDER SECURITY.
IF THAT ARGUMENT APPLIES TO
EUROPE IT DEFINITELY APPLIES
OVER HERE AS WELL.
SHE IS CONSISTENT ABOUT IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT, SHE
IS.
YOU ARE THE MAN AT THE
BORDER.
TELL US WHAT IS GOING ON
THERE AND TELL US WHAT IS
WRONG WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SAYING
THAT IF YOU WANT TO SEEK
ASYLUM, COME IN THE RIGHT
WAY, COME THROUGH A LEGAL,
YOU KNOW, ENTRANCE?
>> THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH WHAT HE IS SAYING.
JUDGE, THE REALITY IS WE NOW
HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT HE IS
DOING WHAT NO OTHER
PRESIDENT HAS DONE.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH MAKING
SURE THAT OUR NATIONS ARE
SHORT OF POINTING A GUN AND
R50EU68, HE HAS DONE
EVERYTHING HE CAN NOW UP TO
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO
COME TOGETHER AND DO THE
RIGHT THING AND HELP OUT
WITH THE BILL HE IS TRYING
TO PRESENT.
I WILL BE HONEST, IT FALLS
ON THE LEADERSHIP WITHIN THE
DHS AND HOMELAND SECURITY.
THIS IS A MAN THAT'S ON
POINT AND HE IS SHOWING HE
CARES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT SIDE
OF THE AISLE YOU'RE ON, YOU
WANT SECURITY IN YOUR
BORDERS.
YOU WANT SECURITY IN YOUR
HOME.
EVERYONE LOCKS THEIR DOORS
AT NIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
YOU SAID SOMETHING.
IT COMES DOWN TO THE LEADERS
OF HOMELAND SECURITY AND
THAT WOULD BE KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN.
WHAT IS SHE NOT DOING RIGHT
OR WHAT IS SHE DOING WRONG?
>> WHAT I'M SAY SOMETHING
NEED TO GET ON THE RIGHT
PATH.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT
SAYING I NEED TO YOU STOP
CATCH AND RELEASE AND CATCH
AND RELEASE IS NOT STOPPED,
I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> Judge Jeanine: SEAN
SPICER, YOU WERE THERE WHEN
ALL OF THIS -- WHEN YOU WERE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WITH THE
CATCH AND RELEASE.
IT WAS STARTED WITH THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT COUNTY PRESIDENT DO
ABOUT THAT ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THIS FEDERAL JUDGE,
YOU KNOW, EVERY TIME HE DOES
SOMETHING, AND WE'RE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THIS IN THE
NEXT SEGMENT.
YOU HAVE A FEDERAL JUDGE
WILLING TO STOP IT.
WHAT ABOUT CATCH AND
RELEASE.
HOW DO WE CHANGE THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK THIS
PRESIDENT HAS ACTUALLY
CHANGED THE ENTIRE DYNAMIC
BECAUSE HE HAS MADE IT VERY
CLEAR HE HAS TALKED ABOUT
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
STAY IN MEXICO APPLY FOR
ASYLUM THERE UNLESS THEY CAN
PROVE THEY ARE IN IMMINENT
DANGER.
HE HAS UPENDED ALL OF THE
PRECEDENT THAT HAS GONE ON
BEFORE THIS AND TAKEN AWAY
JUST THE TALK AND THE
RHETORIC THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN
FROM SO MANY POLITICIANS AND
REPLACED IT WITH ACTION.
THIS PRESIDENT, I THINK, HAS
TON AS MUCH AS HE POSSIBLY
CAN THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND ACTION.
AND THROUGH HIS
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH DHS.
HE TRULY DOES NEED A PARTNER
IN CONGRESS IN THESE
REMAINING DAYS OF THIS LAME
DUCK CONGRESS TO GIVE HIM
THE FUNDING HE NEEDS FOR
BORDER WALL AND BORDER
SECURITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU AND I
BOTH KNOW THEY DON'T WANT TO
GIVE HIM THE MONEY FOR THE
WALL.
THEY LIMITED THE ACTUAL
BUILDING TO $1.6 BILLION --
I THINK IT'S BILLION.
AND IN THE END, I WILL GO TO
YOU DEROY, THE TRUTH IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE PARTY IS
NOT WORKING WITH HIM AND NOW
HE SAYS I WANT REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS TO COME
TOGETHER.
WHAT LEVERAGE DOES THE
PRESIDENT HAVE?
HE IS TALKING ABOUT SHUTTING
DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
I MEAN, WHAT DOES HE DO?
>> COUPLE THINGS, ONE HE
COULD SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
SECOND THING I THINK ONCE
THESE GUYS COME BACK FROM
THANKSGIVING HE SHOULD KEEP
THE 115TH CONGRESS UP ON
CAPITOL HILL JANUARY 3RD
DEMOCRATS COME IN AND VOTE,
VOTE, VOTE AND LITTER HIS
DESK WITH IMMIGRATION AND
OTHER THINGS.
THE OTHER MESSAGE THAT HAS
TO GO OUT TO ALL THESE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO RUSH
ACROSS THE BORDER IF YOU
WANT TO COME TO AMERICA DO
THE WAY MY MOTHER AND FATHER
DID WHEN THEY LEFT COSTA
RICA THEY WENT TO THE U.S.
EMBASSY AND FILL OUT
APPLICATIONS.
FILL OUT THE PAPERWORK.
COME TO AMERICA, RING THE
FRONT DOORBELL DON'T RUN IN
AND BREAK IN THROUGH THE
BATHROOM WINDOW WHICH IS THE
APPROACH THESE PEOPLE ARE
TAKING NOW.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHEN HE
TALKS ABOUT RING THE
DOORBELL, COME IN, OUR
COUNTRY IS OUR HOME.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU
REFERRED TO THIS -- SOME
PEOPLE TAKE OBJECTION WHEN
YOU CALL IT AN INVASION, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HECK
ELSE TO CALL IT?
>> IT'S AN INVASION.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU CALLED
THEM A HOARD.
THAT WAS A WORD I HADN'T
HEARD.
WHY?
>> BECAUSE IT'S A HUGE GROUP
OF PEOPLE FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY THAT ARE FLYING A
FLAG TO ENTER OUR COUNTRY.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE PEOPLE
SEEKING ASYLUM.
ESCAPING PERSECUTION.
THEY ARE COMING HERE
INVASION PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE
PRESIDENT TO
CRESIDENT TO
CREDIDENT TO
CREDITENT TO
CREDITTOT TO
CREDITTO PTO
CREDITTO PRESIDENT TRUMP GIVE HM
CREDIT BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMY.
THAT'S THE REASON THEY'RE
COMING UP HERE.
THE REALITY IS WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT DOING EVERYTHING
HE CAN AND EVERYONE ELSE
NEEDS TO GET ON BOARD.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WE ALL WANT TO FEEL SECURE
IN OUR HOMES.
>> Judge Jeanine: GO AHEAD,
SEAN.
>> I WILL SAY YOU MENTIONED
AT THE BEGINNING, AMERICA
FIRST ACTION, AMERICA FIRST
PAC HAVE BEEN IN THIS FIGHT
WITH THE PRESIDENT AIRING AT
PUTTING OUT VIDEOS, MAKING
SURE THE RESEARCH IS DONE.
WE WILL MAKE SURE WE DO OUR
PART TO SPREAD THE WORD
ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES ARE DOING AND PUT
PRESSURE ON CONGRESS AS WE
HEAD INTO THE FINAL DAYS OF
THIS CONGRESS.
>> Judge Jeanine: ABSOLUTELY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS SO IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW IS THAT TIJUANA HAS
ACTUALLY DECLARED A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
AND, YOU KNOW, APPARENTLY,
AS THIS CARAVAN HAS BEEN
MOVING, GENTLEMEN, THEY HAVE
STAYED ONE OR TWO NIGHTS IN
A PARTICULAR TOWN.
THE TOWN IS HAPPY TO GIVE
THEM FOOD AND GIVE THEM, YOU
KNOW A PLACE TO STAY.
BUT I THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE CRISIS, YOU KNOW,
GUATEMALA AND TIJUANA.
BUT TIJUANA IN PARTICULAR,
IN ADDITION TO SOME OF THE
SILENCE THAT WE ARE SEEING,
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE SAYING,
LOOK, WE NEED THE UNITED
NATIONS TO COME IN.
THIS CARAVAN IS OUT OF
CONTROL.
GO AHEAD, DEROY.
>> ALSO MY QUESTION HERE IS
WHERE IS IT WRITTEN THAT
ANYBODY HAS THE RIGHT TO
COME INTO THIS COUNTRY.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE IT.
>> IF YOU LEAVE HONDURAS AND
GET INTO MEXICO YOU ARE
LEAVING A COUNTRY FOUR TIMES
WEALTHY THAN HONDURAS IS
THAT'S PRETTY COMFORTABLE.
THEY SAID WE WILL GIVE YOU
HOMES AND EDUCATION AND WELL
FAIR.
THEY SHOULD TAKE.
THEIR ATTITUDE GWATNEY LA
GWATNEY LA HARRAHS WON'T DO.
THEY DON'T ASK PERMISSION TO
COME IN HERE.
GENIAL JEAN I'M GOING TO GO
RIGHT TO YOU.
WHY ARE THEY NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF WHAT MEXICO IS
OFFERING THEM?
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT.
TO SAY IT'S NOT THAT THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR ASYLUM.
THEY ARE LOOKING TO COME
INTO THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE THEY PROBABLY HAVE
JOBS ALREADY LINED UP HERE.
THEY PROBABLY HAVE PEOPLE
ALREADY HERE THAT ARE
WAITING FOR THEM.
THAT'S THE REALITY.
THEY WANT TO INVADE OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY WANT TO COME IN HERE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEM.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
AND IT'S NOT A RACE ISSUE.
PEOPLE NEED TO GET AWAY FROM
THIS.
YOU ARE SEEING THE MAYOR OF
TIJUANA AND EVERYTHING HE IS
SAYING.
NO ONE IS CALLING HIM A
RACIST.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S
RIGHT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID
ALL THE RIGHT THINGS AND YOU
TURN AROUND AND CALL IT A
RACIST STATEMENT HERE.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
RACE.
ILLEGAL IS NOT A RACE.
ILLEGAL IS SIMPLY ILLEGAL.
THERE IS A RIGHT WAY TO DO
THINGS AND WRONG WAY TO DO
THINGS.
>> Judge Jeanine: SO WELL
SAID.
SEAN, I WILL GO TO YOU.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I SAW
TODAY WAS A VIDEO WHERE ONE
OF THESE CARAVAN MEMBERS IS
YELLING OPEN THE GATES,
TRUMP.
WE ARE LOOKING TO COME IN.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR WORK.
I MEAN, CAN YOU IMAGINE
WHILE THEY FLY THE FLAG OF
THEIR OWN COUNTRY THEY SAY
TRUMP OPEN THE GATES.
I MEAN, AND GOD FORBID YOU
TRY TO DEPORT THEM TO THAT
COUNTRY THEY ARE WAVING THE
FLAG ON.
THAT'S WHY THEY WANT TO GET
ON OUR SOIL SO THEY CAN
IMMEDIATELY HAVE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
SEAN?
>> INVASION.
>> THEY RECOGNIZE THE FACT
THAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
CREATED AN AMAZING ECONOMY
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THERE IS TON OF JOBS
AVAILABLE.
AND THEY SEE THAT THEY WANT
TO COME UP HERE FOR THE
JOBS.
BUT, AT THE SAME TIME, THE
PRESIDENT HAS CONTINUED TO
BE TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION.
HE UNDERSTANDS WE HAVE TO
HAVE BORDER SECURITY SO THAT
THERE IS THIS CATCH-22.
IS HE CREATING AN AMAZING
ECONOMY WHERE THERE IS TONS
OF JOBS TO GO AROUND AND
PEOPLE ARE USING THAT AS A
MAGNET TO WANT TO COME INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR.
WE ARE STILL A COUNTRY OF
IMMIGRANTS WELCOMING COUNTRY
BUT YOU HAVE TO DO IT
LEGALLY.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO HAVE LAW
AND ORDER.
HE WANTS TO HAVE A VIBRANT
COUNTRY THAT CONTINUES TO
WELCOME PEOPLE BUT DO SO IN
AN ORDERLY WAY.
JEAN JEAN THE WAY THEY ARE
SUPPOSED.